hey everyone welcome to our webinar my
name is Lauren Kwan and I'm on the Kahn
Academy team and today I am joined by my
coworker dance you and our special guest
Connor Corey Connor is an expert teacher
a parent and a Khan Academy ambassador
which means he's a Khan Academy power
user and he's gonna be sharing out his
tips and advice on student motivation
but before we get started I wanted to
thank our sponsors Bank of America AT&T
google.org Novartis and Beth Lee for
their support of this webinar and our
other remote learning resources in a few
other notes for you to know this webinar
will be recorded and sent to you via
email a few hours after the session ends
and if you have questions at any point
during the webinar feel free to enter
them in the question box and we have
staff staff available to answer your
questions we're also gonna save time at
the end for live Q&A with Connor and
lastly you might be wondering about the
age range for this webinar so Connor
will be sharing tips that can be useful
for parents of kids off of all ages so
with that let's get started I'm thrilled
to have connor here to share his advice
Connor can you share a little bit about
yourself in your background
hyaline thanks for having me everybody
yes I've now been a math educator mostly
teaching middle school math and fifth
grade math for seven this is my seventh
year and by far this is the toughest
year for myself and my students right
now I have I also have four children of
my own and it is chaos for myself to
teach a might to try to keep up with you
know three of them are in school one is
in preschool but to keep up with all
their assignments and to keep up to make
sure they're handing things in and to
fully change the role from not only my
students teacher to my own children it's
been very difficult and I you know look
forward the opportunity hopefully I can
help and just maybe some of the things
that I'm doing around here but I think
that I may not have all the answers I
can kind of just tell you from my own
experience
variance of teaching and being a parent
at the same time that hopefully you can
see both sides of the spectrum fantastic
yeah Connor as as you mentioned
a lot of parents are finding themselves
stepping into the role of teachers for
the first time and we're doing so many
questions from parents about ways to
motivate their kids so what advice would
you give to parents who are wondering
how do I motivate my kids to be
interested in learning it's a great
question and it's a difficult question
there's not really one answer that's
going to motivate children across the
board
especially for even myself I'm gonna
tell you that all my kids are eating
bring pops upstairs just to avoid me for
a half hour of coming down here so I can
do this and many parents are in that
same situation but to motivate students
and shoot your own children I've always
kind of tied it to some sort of
incentives and it's never a really
financial incentive it's always just
kind of your time or something that they
really are interested in and it does not
have to be academic related could be
something as simple as you know you
finish out your schoolwork today then
where you get to pick tonight's movie or
my daughter is I do construction in the
summertime usually and my daughter is
very interested in power tools she sees
me building so I'm teaching her how to
use those in when she finishes her stuff
I know my wife who has probably never
played a video game in her life but my
son and I will play Madden he's in third
grade and we will play all the time
because I'm a giant child but my wife
has started to play against him and he
doesn't care if I play anymore he wants
to play her because it's so different
for him to see her in that type of
environment and taking interest in what
he's interested in and that has been
motivating for him so I think if you
just try to find something your child is
interested in that you usually would not
participate in or you could kind of let
them participate with their friends you
know they're not really around the front
anymore so they need somebody that wants
to just kind of reinforce their
interests and I think that's a big
motivator
you can kind of tie that to their
academics yeah I love those creative
ideas that you've shared there and
another question that we're hearing a
lot is how do I keep my kids focused and
engaged in learning focus and engage I
mean it's kind of one of the hardest
parts of our parents who have just been
given an unrealistic expectation to
automatically become their teacher so
automatically have mastered grade-level
content in not one subject but four or
five or six subjects I know for myself
as a teacher I am a master of middle
school math but if you give me an eighth
grade biology test I'm not going to do
well so when you're just pushing all of
a sudden all of this on parents they're
very stressed out and their children
fully understand that they don't get the
concepts or the content as much my
suggestion for this is to try to learn
something with them if for instance like
with Khan Academy I always tell parents
they didn't experiment a few years ago
where I asked parents to master their
child's fifth or for their child's
content on Khan Academy so their child's
grade level and what I felt from that
was amazing most parents have bought out
of math after third grade it becomes oh
my god I don't know how they're teaching
you this I don't know this new style of
math but the linear approach that Khan
Academy gives to learn anything was
tastic for them to see that okay this is
how they're teaching math and it's just
something if you try fourth grade math
in your child maybe in seventh or eighth
grade and they're doing seventh or
eighth grade you kind of do it alongside
them for 15 minutes 10 minutes a day
that has been a huge help with
understanding where to find relevant
content where your child has any
misunderstanding because it doesn't have
to be in math it could be in science and
chemistry in history and SAT prep all of
that is available but if you're looking
for a video to help your child you
may go through Google and you'll have 30
different websites and you start to find
one you don't know how relevant or
accurate it is and you're spending so
much time trying to find one thing if
you work through something like Khan
Academy on like a fourth grade level
priced how the whole spectrum of
education will open up and the
understanding will open up of how to
find content to help your child and
they're gonna be engaged because they're
doing it with you and they're gonna
laugh at you when you get things wrong
because you will surprise sounds
difficult third or fourth grade math can
be assured with them is probably the
best way yeah and speaking of yeah it's
been a while I'm sure it's been a while
for parents for third or fourth grade
math and so if kids you know for example
if they get frustrated do you have any
tips for keeping kids engaged if they
get frustrated if they get things wrong
yes and right now most children are
frustrated they're used to having expert
in that content area who knows how to
teach that content area ten different
ways and knows how to reach every child
and the different learning styles of
every child and now they have just you
know their parent who may not even
understand some of the content and the
frustration level for parents and
students is at an all-time high in
education so my going back they kind of
paralleling if you learn something with
your child in practice and try to teach
them like the theory of growth mindset
that show them that you're frustrated
learning something like fourth grade
math and that they're gonna laugh when
you get things wrong and that you try it
again the next day and you try it again
the next say that like kind of theory of
growth mindset that we all can learn
anything is something that if we teach
our children at a young age and at a
difficult time right now will be so
important moving forward because we
actually don't know when this is all
going to end and to understand this
platform the kind of practice learning
with them they will see you doing that
and that's going to cause less
for them when you can kind of both laugh
at each other that you're working
through it yeah definitely growth
mindset definitely something that both
parents and students would be a valuable
skill to build and another other
question that we hear as well from
parents is how do I keep my kids engaged
if they don't like school it's tough
right now because I don't know that
anybody likes school as a teacher I do
not I'm teaching from my basement I
think I set up a nice little area for
myself but I miss my students I miss
seeing their faces in live time students
are now being sent assignments across
the board from five or six teachers and
parents are now getting thirty to forty
websites and logins where three the
three of my children that are in the
public school system right now each have
like ten different logins and then you
have some people that are sending oh
here's a new one try this here's a new
one try this and it's so overwhelming
that you have to sometimes just really
like take a step back and make sure that
your child is enjoying learning and not
overwhelmed just you and that may take
cutting certain assignments out it may
take taking a look through and saying
we're not going to do this because it
took my daughter the other day five
minutes to do a digital assignment that
she had but it was taking her 25 minutes
to submit it and then I'm trying to do
it and she's trying to submit it she's
telling me well no we have to put it on
Google classroom and then we have to go
to this and and that is not learning
she wasn't gaining anything valuable
about that so for me as a parent I just
kind of said we're done yeah you did she
did it with me I get it we're moving on
and if your teacher wants to send me an
email or I can send her one and say I
did it she explained it to me but
they're having them answer questions
some of them on the little tiny mouse
pad where they have to write on that
mouse pad and that is so difficult I
can't do it but they're answering one
little question
takes 10 to 15 minutes for them just to
write the sentence out like well she
told me she if she understands it
they're good it's finished as the parent
you have that right and I think you
should use it because the stress level
is so high sure yeah and I should point
out I forgot to mention earlier that
Conners summarize hopefully summarize
many of his tips and a handout that you
all can get in your GoToWebinar panel
under the handout so if you want to go
ahead and grab that I would definitely
recommend it so Connor we're hearing
also from parents and you touched on
this earlier but there but what tips
would you give for parents who are
trying to teach kids of a subject that
they're not comfortable or familiar with
the material themselves except that you
don't know the material let your
children understand that you don't know
the material and kind of together learn
it or together find ways to do it
but what is happening that I see in my
own house and I talked of many friends
who call me because they I'm the only
teacher that they know the learning
doesn't seem to be happening as much as
the handing the learning in and doing
these things and parents that with so
many logins they're not sure where to go
they're not sure how to find it and I
think Khan Academy will help with that
if you start to work yourself and learn
that platform because I feel next year
as we come back to school that every
district in the country will be using
this platform and it's going to kind of
give you a head start so it's not so
much about now and having to understand
the content that you're teaching but how
you can help your child find the answers
and how you can navigate through and
have a spot for them almost like a
one-stop of Education where you know
you're going to get relevant information
and then maybe you can watch the video
with them and how to do things with them
but we're at a time where we have to
start looking that if something like
this were to happen again I should
prepare myself for when it happens again
and not worry about getting to June and
ending but
of preparing myself to learn how to help
my child when or if something like this
were to happen again so I think here you
may is for one platform it's a really
positive thing you could do for your
check great
well I wanted to have plenty of time to
answer Q&A from the audience so I'll
turn it over to Dan to surface some
questions that we've been hearing from
from audience members yes thanks Lauren
and Thank You Connor for joining us I'm
super excited to have you here we have
tons of excitement and enthusiasm around
this specific topic I'd ask the audience
to do two things before we get into a
live Q&A session first go to as Lauren
mentioned go to the handout section and
grab the tips and cheechee the Connor
that kind of put together their really
good tips and you know you can download
it and also just review links to other
resources that we've included in there
as well and then the second prompt is to
please add your questions we already
have a ton of questions coming in and
the message boards so keep those going
in coming in and we'll get to as many as
we can just ask that you be patient with
us okay so Connor we have quite a few
questions one from Kimberly another one
from Pamela it's really around I think I
guess some of the kids you know ages
sixth grade they're not listening to
their parents or they're saying they're
doing one thing you know they're looking
at the site if they're caught up in the
class and when the parent actually
checks in you know that's not the case
so do you have any advice with that you
know for parents who are kind of
struggling with keeping not being
overbearing but also just being able to
keep track of how their kids are
progressing with their school it's
important to understand that although
you're they're your children you know
them they are in middle school in high
school and they're gonna think like a
middle school or a high school kid I
know that I have my own children my own
students they'll spend an hour trying to
beat the system rather than ten minutes
doing the assignment and I've I mean I
tell story one time where I was
requiring 20 minutes
on Khan Academy at night and I had a
student that was doing an hour for
almost a week and a half and I wanted to
reward him for his additional work but
there was no progress being made and I
could not figure it out I actually sent
something to Khan Academy saying
something's wrong because nothing's
moving and then finally he owned up and
said I've been putting nickels on one of
the actual keys for the answer so it
shows his activity but nothing's
actually getting done and he would just
leave nickels a pile of nickels on the
bank and I mean I gave him credit
because I thought it was genius but the
assignments would take you 20 minutes
but for him to do all that so they think
it's important for Paris arrives they're
going to try to beat the system in for
myself we do squeeze have a schedule and
the schedule works for us
what the first thing we know our
schedule is in the morning but for some
parents it's not everyone thinks that
school should be eight to three because
that's what it was but it does not have
to be that it could be at any time
throughout the day that works for you
that works for your family and for us I
make my children write a checklist each
morning when they kind of check their
email when they check their Google
classroom that I don't leave it on their
computer on their own and they have to
kind of hand me a checklist at breakfast
though by this I have this save this and
I this and we've scheduled throughout
the day I'm discussing with you prior to
this thing we have different rooms for
each subjects in the house so it is in
the kitchen they do their language arts
and if they're all in the kitchen I know
they're working on language arts they
come to the basement where I am at right
now for to work on their math and then
they go into the living room to work on
their social studies or science but it's
a quick way for me to see if they're
getting through their curriculum for the
day and also if I have the checklist I
can kind of say did you do this did you
do this but I don't have to go on to
each one of my children's thing and
write it myself
and figure out all these things I have
them hand it to me and it's kind of just
a quick checklist for me and them as
well to keep them kind of progressing
through what they're supposed to be
doing
great so Connor we have a question from
Diane Diane Rodriguez and as a teacher I
think you're and a parent you're you're
exceptionally positioned to answer this
question
Diane asks you know I've been using Khan
Academy with my second grader and it's
been very helpful but her point is that
math is being taught very differently
than when she had learned it and so her
concern is that when they go back to
school that she may have been coaching
her child in a different way than and
the way the schools are teaching it now
do you have a perspective you can
concern about that or how should she
approached that this is the question
that has come actually from years I was
a math coach for a few years in
elementary schools and this is why
parents buy out because they know how to
teach which traditional math and
addition and multiplication but then
that's not aligning with what they're
fully teaching my suggestion is always
to teach I actually am an advocate for
traditional multiplication and long
division and I fully grasp the analytics
of breaking everything apart and I think
it has a true value and understanding
however I think they have to master
certain skills like their multiplication
facts and their division facts that they
have to know them just like they know
the alphabet and what sounds letters
make or when you start to get into the
older grades with variables and
exponents you really start to get lost
because you don't have the foundation
and I so for me if you're teaching a
child something method the way you
learned it I think I find that to be
very positive because that's building a
foundation and then when they go back to
school and maybe they change it up they
grasp the foundation of that so to
change the way your learn another way to
do the same thing they already know how
to do it so I would definitely suggest
yes work with your child teach them the
way that they know and on Khan Academy's
second grade third grade it kind of does
both they show in the multiplication in
the division in the addition and
subtraction they show the methods of
breaking it apart and they also show the
traditional carrying from the ones to
the tens column
when attends to the hundreds cow but I
would think if you're teaching them
something there's always value in that
so to continue to do that and not to try
to worry about what the school system
has done or is doing because right now a
lot of teachers are required to throw
assignments at kids and they're not when
I'm teaching I can say that you know
Susie when she choose her pen I know she
doesn't understand anything I'm saying
but I can't see that right now or when
Jacob nods I know he has no clue what's
going on so I just stop and kind of go
through that with them and that's what
teachers do while they're teaching that
so I would think that whenever they come
back they're going to be fine especially
if you think about maybe not in second
grade but fright around now schools
don't want to admit it but we're in
standardized test season and they may
not want to talk about the majority of
stuff we're doing is just review we're
not teaching really new content as much
as we're reviewing and spiraling the
content we've already taught throughout
the year and that takes four to five
weeks of review and then two weeks of
testing and then we're getting really
getting to the end of the year so I
think it's important to understand that
whatever you're doing with a child
reviewing it's helpful and it's gonna
hold value for them as they come back
yeah kinda I wouldn't even be able to
teach the new ways of math anyway even
if I wanted to so I don't have a
question from Alexis Leacock who's who's
asking our child is only willing to do
what the teachers assign and teachers
aren't assigning much right now
especially in science so no science
content any ideas in terms of how to
continue learning when teachers aren't
stepping up and she won't hear it from
us at meeting the parents so this really
comes down to yourself as a parent I
think that teachers we don't know
exactly what to do right now either and
we're dealing with parents from every
end of the spectrum just like parents
are dealing with teachers from every end
of the spectrum I I know the teachers
that are requiring like two hours of
work a day and
I know teachers that are requiring five
minutes and it's how they're viewing
what is going on that if their class was
two hours they should have two hours of
work if an other teachers realize that
you know the unemployment rate is at an
all-time high parents are trying to stay
in the house they're trying to make sure
they can put food on the table and
something as a Google slide assignment
may not have that value I would suggest
if you're looking at like high school
parents they want to learn science or
they want additional work to increase
what's happening that you use something
like Khan Academy and Shotton provide it
to them yourself
and you don't have to know their content
this is what I mean why it's so powerful
it's free and you can say I require you
to do 20 minutes on you know biology and
that's something that you require of
them and those you can actually say did
they do the 20 minutes did they watch
the video did they do the practice
exercise and those scores will come up
directly to your email and it could have
nothing to do with the school district
but I think we do have to plan long term
for what's happening everyone is looking
towards June but I think the most
effective thing you can do right now is
start to get your children in a routine
for this summer most of this take off in
the summer with education with our
children and there's going to be a
Summer Slide every year but this year
it's so critical not to end in June to
make sure that it doesn't have to be a
full day it could be okay every day the
20 minutes of math 20 minutes of
literacy and I want that routine to
happen throughout the summer also so
maybe I don't know what standard it is
and what grade but I know you're
consistently learning and you're
consistently working and I think that's
gonna be one of the most positive things
that you can do but we do all have the
ability to teach our children we've
taught them everything they know
maybe not academic we thought them to
ride a bike you talk about a tie their
shoes you taught them manners how they
act in public and they're watching you
right now to see what they should do in
this
so and is setting a new routine and
realizing we probably are not going back
to the way things were anything soon
Connor I would just piggyback off that I
think part of is just setting
expectations with yourself as an adult I
think there a lot of parents are
expecting that as you mentioned earlier
that this is a normal like eight hours
of school timeframe that kids would be
doing at home and I think that's
honestly just unrealistic for most
parents I mean one we just don't have
the time between the work that you would
have to do you know also just all the
other myriad things and teachers are in
the same position as well so I think you
know for we're getting some questions
around like if we're not getting enough
assignments how should we fill in the
gap and I would say part of it is you
know your own ability to fill in the gap
as a parent and if you do have the extra
time to make extra assignments feel free
to do that you know use Khan Academy as
Connor suggested if you do but also just
with the understanding that it's not a
normal school day that your child is
going to be going through and honestly
that's okay like I don't think the
expectation is that you're going to
learn physics and then be able to teach
your kid physics in one week for example
so just be kind to yourself and just
have a different set of expectations for
now and I great I think it's important
to also realize if you need additional
things for a child to do it does not
have to be academic related teach them
how to build something teach them how to
let them maybe paint the room and teach
them in of paint my daughter has changed
his changing electrical sockets with me
because she sees me doing it and I'm
always like alright now I make sure the
electrics off and they said but she's
interested so that's something and
that's a skill and like I know when she
goes off the college she's got to be
able to she needs to I don't hope that
she will but she's not a doodler laundry
teach them life skills that you've done
for them so far and try to start to take
some of that off of you and teach it to
them because everything is not about the
8:00 to 3:00 school day and in that
school day
there is lunch there's recess there's
transition times there is a movie in the
one class there's there's different
things it's not eight straight
powers of somebody giving worksheets I
hope not anyway yeah yeah and in
Kanagawa we provided daily learning you
know daily schedules for for families to
use and we're kind of doing the same
thing where we're advising to mix it up
so have you know off-screen activities
and that obviously also helps with the
motivation factor right so they're not
you know sitting at home in front of
their computer for eight hours watching
a course on they're actually getting up
and mixing up different activities I
love the suggestion of you know being a
maker you know create something and
you're still building a different skill
it doesn't have to be academics eight
hours a day because honestly that's
probably not gonna work at this time
work for me wait I think we have time
for one more question so here's a
question from Monica and Virginia as a
parent of a second grader is it
counterproductive to allow flexibility
and scheduling in instruction I'm
following the schedule like into what
the child was conditioned to when school
was in session so I guess it's it's the
the question is really is it kind of
productive to have a flexibility or is
it better to kind of stick to a more
rigid schedule I do not believe you
should stick to the standard school
schedule that they're used to because
school is not what they're used to right
now so it's not like you're going into
the school building and changing what
happens but you have to make something
that's working for you and your family
and if like for instance my wife worked
was able to work from home and she's
still employed and still working from
home but I always went to school that
was the schedule I left at 6:30 in the
morning and she kind of did breakfast
and did all that and then when the kids
went on the bus then she would start
work well I'm trying to give her time
while I take all the kids so I'm doing
breakfast then it's kind of funny it's
that they're like oh wait for breakfast
they go and I'll have eggs all this like
I meant did you want toast or cereal
you know I'm not mom but I know that
we'll do stuff but if it's all the
sudden nice if the Sun comes out for 20
minutes we're cutting everything off and
we're going to
to go in the yard it's been raining here
in Philadelphia it seems like every day
and yesterday they had the Blue Angels
actually fly over Philadelphia so that
was like an hour and a half in the
middle of the day where we sat in the
yard and kind of looked up and did
different things and maybe they did
their literacy at six o'clock at night
after dinner or maybe they did it here
as long as they understand what they
have to do throughout the day they're
gonna start to manage their time even at
a young age but to put yourself through
that stress that stress who's gonna go
right to your child and when you're
stressed and your child stressed because
you're trying to conform to a system
that's not working for you there will
not be learning that takes place and
it's why online learning is so popular
in college and for parents because they
can't conform to that so that's why they
can't go back to school that's why
online learning has become so popular
for adults and graduates and the same
things going on right now so
unfortunately we're already at time when
we have like a thousand more questions
to get through perhaps we'll do another
kind of follow-up session in the future
but Connor I wanted to thank you so much
for joining us and sharing your
expertise with our family in Lauren
thank you for for moderating the first
half of this conversation and I also
want to thank you the parent busy
parents out there I know you've already
have you know a million things to do as
part of your your day but thank you for
joining us in this afternoon for this
live session I just want to reiterate if
you missed any part of this or if you
want to go back and review some of the
some of the comments and the Q&A portion
we will be posting recording of this
webinar live and Connor's tips are free
and downloadable as well and both of
these will be emailed to those who have
already registered after this as well
along with links to resources at Khan
Academy org so we have a suite of other
parent resources that are available on
our website there's a blue ribbon at the
top dedicated really to school closures
and remote learning so feel free to
visit that and then before we sign off
we ask you to do us one more favor and
take the poll that pops up at the very
end of this webinar to help us answer
two questions first how can we make
future iterations of this session even
better for you all and then
secondly what kind of other sessions
would you like to see us develop in the
future we're here to support you
you know this session was really created
because this was probably the number one
requested webinar by by you all and so
we hope to be able to do more of that
for you in the future and in closing you
know on behalf of Connor and I'm behalf
Lauren and myself I mean you know we
appreciate that you're doing a lot as
parents and we're dealing with all this
all of us together you know with this
uncharted territory all at the same time
and we want to remind you as parents to
be kind to yourself you know Connor
mentioned it we know you're struggling
with just balancing work and multiple
kids and trying to be a teacher now and
all those things and just be patient
with yourself and that's okay if you
mess up here and there that's what
growth mindset is about is just you know
making some of these mistakes learning
from them and then progressing that way
as well so from all of us at Khan
Academy thanks again and good night
thank you thanks for having me I
appreciate it
you